so cpac the annual conservative confab
happened this past
weekend usually in the dc area this time
it was held in florida
several controversies erupted out of the
gathering this year
as can be expected but none more
important or disturbing
than the revelation as exposed by a
great many left-wing media outlets and
journalists online
that the entire cpac stage in the main
event hall
was really a giant secret nazi symbol
according to the conspiracy theorists
who are the good kind of conspiracy
theorists remember not the bad kind
according to them the stage was in
effect a dog whistle a message
to the underground army of white
supremacist nazis in this country it was
a sort of
bat signal you might say if batman was a
nazi and frankly
given that he was rich and white he
probably was a nazi come to think of it
in any event many frantic tweets um like
this one were sent out on saturday this
is from a guy named ben
jackson who writes for a number of media
outlets and he said
this is the cpac stage it is designed
below it is a rune which was used by the
ss this is the stage from which ted cruz
screeched
freedom now elise hogue who's the
president of neral
a militant pro-abortion organization
chimed in and said
the cpac stage resembles a known ss nazi
insignia
generously let's assume the design was
an error
they should immediately release an
apology and change up the stage
not doing so will convey the most
reprehensible intent
uh okay all right well all they have to
do is literally tear down their stage
and rebuild it
in the middle of the event if they don't
do that then they're nazis
so what's it going to be cpac are you
going to call in a construction crew and
rebuild your stage while president trump
is standing on it to speak
or will you admit your nazis those are
your two choices
checkmate now here's slate with uh more
information
about the nazi stage they say quote matt
schlapp the head of the american
conservative union
who organizes the uh conservative
political action conference
is pushing back against those who said
that the stage for the event that is
taking place in orlando is eerily
reminiscent to a
nazi symbol quote stage design
conspiracies are outrageous and
slanderous
schlapp tweeted he went on to say that
cpac proudly stands with our jewish
allies
the fact that schlapp felt the need to
comment on the issue illustrates just
how pervasive the comparisons had become
on social media as many pointed out that
the shape of the stage
looked like a nazi symbol specifically
many said the stage
looked like a version of the odol rune
also referred to as the othalla rune
the symbol dates back centuries but was
also used by some nazi ss divisions
during world war ii the symbol was
emblazoned on uniforms of some nazi
soldiers
okay there you go the stage looked like
the othalarune
which was used by some nazi ss divisions
in world war ii
what you didn't you didn't know what the
oh thala rune was and had no idea that
this seemingly innocuous shape
was associated with it and what's that
you have not memorized
every shape and insignia that appeared
on every uniform of every nazi division
well that's only because you're a nazi
yourself
or wait a second maybe that doesn't make
any sense see personally
i saw the cpac stage and thought nothing
of it because i'm not an
expert on obscure nazi symbolism
a lot of leftists apparently are such
experts or pretend to be
which leaves us with two options either
these spec these people spend
a lot of time studying nazis and nazi
symbolism
and are super into it which raises all
kinds of suspicions if you ask me
or more likely almost all of them had no
idea that this shape had anything to do
with the nazis
but then they learned about it on
twitter and immediately decided that it
was impossible that the cpac organizers
could have been as ignorant as they were
on the subject
this is a common move on the internet of
course not just people
you know accusing people of being nazis
that's common but also the thing where
you learn about something and then five
seconds later you're mocking everybody
else for not knowing the thing that you
also didn't know prior to five seconds
ago
but the whole controversy does raise two
points um
first of all though i know that pointing
out double standards from the left
seems rather fruitless at this point i
do have to make this observation
these people just a few weeks ago were
canceling gina carano for making a nazi
comparison
and now here they are comparing the cpac
stage designers to nazis
because the shape vaguely resembles an
old nordic symbol that some
ss divisions briefly used on their
uniforms 80 years ago
so we're used to the hypocrisy of course
but this is egregious even by left-wing
standards
second it's worth reflecting on the fact
that
the people accusing cpac of
intentionally setting up its stage to
look like a nazi symbol
are not all being disingenuous i mean
certainly a portion of them are
some of them know how ridiculous the
claim is and are saying it anyway
good old-fashioned political slander but
the really disturbing and
also kind of remarkable thing is that
many of these people truly believe it
they truly believe that the cpac stage
was a nazi symbol
because they truly believe that cpac
itself is a nazi gathering
and that conservatives in general are
mostly nazis
i know we're used to this also by now
but but think about it
really think about it if you're a
conservative
a sizable number of your ideological
opponents honest to god believe
that you are an actual nazi or nazi
sympathizer
the people putting this idea into their
heads they know better
but the average dupe doesn't they
believe it
they believe that they are in a fight
against literal
nazis you know that i'm i'm highly
skeptical that there can ever be unity
in this country again
in general i'm skeptical of that but if
it's going to happen
if there's any hope of it happening it
would have to start
bare minimum with the left acknowledging
that their political opponents are not
actual nazis i mean we couldn't unify
simply based on that fact alone we can't
say like yay we're all not nazis
let's unite there needs to be more to it
than that
but admitting that your opponents are
not nazis
is certainly a necessary first step
and on the left even that step is too
much
even that is a bridge too far even that
is more ground than they are willing to
concede
and hopefully if nothing else this will
put into perspective our chances of ever
having unity
at all in this country well i hope you
enjoyed that clip for the matt wall show
if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content